elle avoue que ça c'est la maman ont
connu obligé comme un missile à moi
c'est la moitié nord saf et voilà c'est
pas ça je sais pas comment vous dire
c'est comme ça que je veux dire il entre
au dessus des yeux parce qu'il n'a pas
la marque et la marque et les audiences
hip hop voilà c'est qu'ils vont se dire
je n'aime pas d'ici moi j'aimerais admis
tout le monde s'habille avec des piments
séchés sachant qu'ils ignorent c'est un
petit mail maintenant jean baskets
bleues c'est normal et c'est ce à quoi
vous avez ici mais il faut tout ça ton
choix vous c'est quoi des rigoles de
vous il se moque de vous décollez vais
en faire
tu vois qui va pas trop bien le canada
comme un comique de voir conseil dans ma
commune
[Musique]
flo est une véritable accro de la sape
elle est incollable sur les tendances de
ce qu'elle préfère nommer la mode de la
rue après des années de galère un début
de carrière de basketteuse et 2,3 boulot
de vendeuse
fo a finalement réalisé son rêve créer
des vêtements et des accessoires de mode
repos si possible les gens de jean comme
ça franchement c'est quoi les tendances
actuelles
ben pour moi les tendances actuelles
tout en restant tout ce qui est dit pop
rap ragga
je pense aux baggies par exemple dans ce
style là qu'ils se portent très bas
aussi bien pour les nanas que pour les
garçons qui se prépare très bon pour une
1 h 36 au sexy pour les mecs sera des
grands des gros sweats par exemple comme
ça qu'ils descendent bien toi c'est
assez joli tir et de la mode des états
unis de toute manière ça se répercute
sur ici c'est sur les jeunes
bon beaucoup regardé ce qui les
intéresse genre dans le rap il
s'identifie un peu par rapport à ces
gens là je pense pas me tromper en
disant sain et
ils prennent leurs notes de
personnalités avec ces gens là et en
même temps c'est vraiment contraignant
quoi d'avoir la doudoune qu'il faut la
basket qu'il faut ça coûte cher en plus
leur mode de vie pour soi ça ils s'en
foutent de ça je pense moi je m'en fous
ainsi qu'en pensent ils alors j'ai pas
d'argent je vais pas aller voler pour ça
je pense que non plus vient d'ailleurs
fois parce qu'il faut pas se méprendre
là dessus mais c'est vrai que s'ils
doivent passer quelque chose ils vont
s'acheter quelque chose comme ça parce
qu'ils ont peur ils ont besoin de ça ils
ont besoin de se sentir bien de voir
qu'ils sont des ils vivent dans un
milieu aussi souvent à paris comme en
banlieue dans un milieu défavorisé
donc ils ont ils vivent toujours dans
des dans des milieux sombre lugubre
enfin tu vois j'ai pas tous mais c'est
quand même beaucoup comme ça ils n'ont
pas beaucoup de moyens les parents
galèrent 20 tu vois donc ils ont besoin
d'avoir des belles choses pour montrer
que ils vivent pas que ce à quoi donc
qu'ils ont besoin de toi les gens ils
voyaient que c'est beau ça flashe
champions c'est leur façon de s'exprimer
attendra pas que des signes aussi
résident à soulac
[Musique]
tandis que c'est important à basket moi
j'ai remarqué une chose ça quand tu
manges la rue malheureusement ça sera
vachement triste je regarde quand même
voilà même quand on pense je regarde
c'est tout de suite on va regarder des
ponts alors que c'est tellement mieux de
regarder les yeux parce que sa voiture
en plus d'expression que d'autres ping
en chacun son truc
mais c'est vrai que en majorité c'est
quand même les baskets agents à 15h m'en
viens 700 pensez-vous des cantons
draguer une fille dans la rue moi je
regarde toujours les pieds
après je regarde le au sérieux et c'est
pas répondu quand on marche dans la rue
quand on accoste défi ou quoi que ce
soit la filière gargati jeu sur cache
cache
je regarde si tu vois six mois pour
trouver ou des baskets ancien nom à la
mode et on est moins dur et c est dans
la tendance actuelle or les filles elles
sont plus féminine ou plus masculine
masculine est ce que ça c'est sûr je
pense que
comment ça c'est pareil aussi c'est le
même une notification par rapport au rap
aussi jeu pensant aux clips vidéo
américain et tout mais aussi fait le
phénomène que wind and à la fin
tellement vide à raison d'une soirée où
il y aura un maximum de mecs de smet un
petit truc sexy une petite jupe parce
que c'est très bien car ça reprend de la
tête du début à la fin
elle sera prendre la tête de toute façon
parce qu'elle sera joli et bien sapés
alors un bon look on me dit tu vois mais
en même temps elle va pas se mettre
mais tu crois pas que c'est dommage
j'étais rapport soit devrait évoluer
comme ça c'est à dire que c'est plus dur
quand lé rapport ils sont plus dire quoi
la vie elle est comme ça déjà
donc moi chez que le hip hop ou bon le
rap suis pas comment vous l'appelez mois
chez charles du hip hop il a évolué bon
en fonction de la vie quoi ça c'est plus
dur c'est plus hardcore c'est plus la
rue à la rue c'est le reflet de fin de
tout ça on s'adapte c'est clair les
filles s'habillent comme comme aldi
préfère s'habiller en baggy ou en trucs
un peu plus large pour pas provoquer les
mac pour se fondre dans la masse parce
qu'en fait et ce que première soirée ce
jeudi soir une mecque
on n'est qu'à ou autres augmentant les
fils en crue dans des soirées c'est vrai
que moi à mon copain quand j'étais en
bond construit avec des mecs les meufs
fallait pas qu'on fasse partie de nos
plans quoi les meufs c'était vraiment
gérants vont casser les plans ou si ça
pourquoi ne fait on s'inscrit dans une
histoire
on voit là pour que sa date elle se
fonde tout sinon tu vas chez toi tu fais
tes copines sur la télé et la nsa
copains je commence
la coupe là qu'est tout c'est la mode
c'est la mode des cloches à la main
quand tu vas à l'école oui tu réfléchis
à ce que tu vas porter où tu mets
n'importe quoi surtout le choix je dois
me dire qu'est ce que qu'est ce que je
vais mettre pour la nouvelle sur nombre
de mâts des deux oui et les matins
surtout si j'espère bien sûr va être
qu'il va bien être le avec le reste je
vais pas m c'est par là même un gros
truc c'est ça voilà surtout s'en fout
c'est les filles les femmes à la fin ils
s'aiment bien moi qu'on s'habille ben
moi j'aime toutes les femmes
[Musique]